le mannequin eric genest celui qui était
mieux connu sous le nom de the only boys
qu'on retrouvait même dans cette vidéo
de lady gaga ici vous la voyez à lecture
à l'écran a été trouvé mort hier après
midi à montréal
il s'est enlevé la vie zombie boy il
avait 32 ans il s'est fait connaître
mondialement en 2011 en appel sont donc
dans cette vidéo clip de la chanson de
la chanteuse américaine
il avait fait du mannequinat écoute on
était même rendu à faire des statuts en
son honneur à son effigie on va parler
de lui avec pénélope mcquade animatrice
de l'émission les échangistes nouveau
joint par téléphone
pénélope bonjour merci d'être avec nous
dont l'une est dès lors vous l'avez reçu
samedi boy aux échangiste qu'est ce que
vous avez retenu de lui parler de cette
rencontre mais d'un biberon est un être
évidemment hors norme qui était pas
juste hors norme
en apparence c'est quelqu'un qui avait
un mode de vie hors norme qui avait une
personnalité outil un peu oubliée
évidemment et c'est ce qui a fait sa
popularité à travers le monde l'avait
millions et des millions de fans partout
de la russie jusqu'en afrique c'est
vraiment quelqu'un qui avait ce qu'on
appelle un recours band pays c'est à
dire vraiment un sens loin des gens qui
le suivait avec beaucoup d'intérêt je
pense qu'ils rejoignaient beaucoup de
gens justement parce qu'ils étaient
atypiques et je pense que beaucoup de
gens se reconnaissaient en lui et bas
dans cette façon qu'il avait d'assumer
la différence évidemment différente qui
écrit beaucoup mis en lumière vous
l'avez vu par le vidéoclip de lady gaga
mais entre autres des années car il nous
l'a fait appel à lui pour défiler sur
ses passes 13 quelqu'un qui était apparu
dans les pages du thiou du vote du
vanity fair c'est vraiment quelqu'un qui
attisait la curiosité publique et
c'était un être prêt d'en jouer quand
j'ai reçu deux ans à l'émission c'est
très particulier c'est une entrevue luc
particulière je pense et j'espère dans
les dernières années
c'était quelqu'un qui a la foi était un
peu prisonnier de cette image là à
plusieurs reprises dans l'émission ils
t'attendent est de nous être qu'on lui
pose des questions qu'ils fassent
ressortir son côté un peu freak show
vous savez on peut exposer comme une
bête de cirque à travers les années
quelqu'un qui était tatoué soit 90 % de
son corps et il était un peu à la fois
il s'amusait de ce regard qu'on avait
sur lui c'est quelqu'un qui à l'instar
mansanné qui je pense était un peu
prisonnier de cette image l'oeil de la
curiosité publique une vie hors norme
aussi un gène qui avait été la team d'un
cancer nous a fait majeur au cerveau qui
a dû subir à l âge de 15 ans une
opération et c'est un peu ce qu'elle
fait basculer sa vision du monde et
c'est comme ça que tu allumage est entré
dans sa vie
en fait oui maintenant au cerveau il a
reçu son surnom de zombie boy est apparu
dans ta vie après ce à partir de la même
famille les parents étaient très fiers
de lui
mais l'accord n'est jamais aucune
entrevue vous ne parlez jamais de lui
par son autorisation ils étaient très
respectueux de sa façon de vivre de ce
qu'il était devenu
comme il compte en quelque sorte à
l'échelle mondiale mais c'est vrai qu'à
part cela je ne sais pas équipés domaine
familial ni à quoi tu es un peu partout
il commence à faire tatouer à l'âge de
19 ans c'est quelqu'un qui vivait de
nuit qui vivaient dans la rue qui
embrassait ce mode de vie le il avait un
très grand encouragement des vues sur le
plateau ya deux ans avait reçu parce
qu'il avait fait un digestif dans le
cadre de juste pour rire il travaillait
sur un cd de musique oscille musique
électronique métal donc c'est quelqu'un
qui avait un style de vie qui était très
attirant
on était curieux d'avoir un peu comment
ils vivaient c'est quoi ça sert parce
que bon il est né à lasalle vous l'avez
dit son nom c'est vrai que je n'ai donc
go de montréal d'une famille tout ce qui
est à nîmes brière donc tout ce qui est
de plus peut-être type et tout ce qu'on
peut considérer comme normal mais c'est
vrai qu'à partir d'un certain âge s'est
mis à vivre un peu dans la rue je sais
qu'on a fait état aujourd'hui en fait de
ses possibles problèmes de santé mentale
ce qui est un document que moi j'ai
perçu comme étant quelqu'un d'un peu
fragile mais qui étaient présents
jouer peut-être un peu mal à l'aise
également même pas ils émettent avec les
gens il aimait le contact est là mais
j'ai l'impression qu'il cherchait un peu
tape la véritable à travers et
prisonnier cette image comme on dit
tellement frappante parce qu'évidemment
c'est impossible pour lui de passer
inaperçu et sa vie est tellement
radicalement changé eu plusieurs
fractures dans ces villes il ya eu cet
épisode de maladie cette opération
quitté la famille jeunes de venir un
jeune de la rue et finalement un peu
avec la public à publier les données la
vidéo évidemment lady gaga de basculer
dans le monde de la mode où il est connu
quand vous êtes des millions de fans
c'est que rien et il ya un point chaud
mais ça aussi oui quand même
c'est quelqu'un qui a eu un statut de
star partons apparent donc c'est quand
même pas rien à voir une statue au musée
grévin à son image donc c'est quelque
chose qu'ils allumaient il amusé en fait
beaucoup mais c'est vrai on peut penser
je peux pas imaginer ce que c'est quand
on tombe à ce que justement dans une
cellule au jt de ce type pour une raison
très particulière donc ses tatouages
mais effectivement c'est quelque chose
que j'ai senti un peu de santé à est il
tenté à trouver sa véritable nature
qu'est ce qui pouvait émerger de sa part
dans l'apparence donc comme j'ai reçu à
eux deux en parler du coût de sa musique
de ce qui l'allumé de ce qu'ils avaient
envie de faire malheureusement qui est
pour moi le plus troublant dans toute
cette histoire c'est qu'on assiste pour
la troisième fois en quelques mois un
suicide une personnalité connue qui de
l'extérieur semble avoir tout ce sont
bien des gens rise et je pense à anthony
bourdain france accueille notamment dans
les derniers mois c'est donc moi c'est
cet aspect là un petit m'inquiète auprès
de ces femmes c'est elles qui m'inquiète
parce qu'ils ont une image c'est la
célébrité de ce que c'est que d'être
rendu un endroit où bien des gens râlent
pas être et c'est ce décalage entre ce
qu'il représentait et s'il use et
intérieurement et moi c est plus une
pensée pour tous les gens qu'il trouve
pas sa place pour le pour tous ces gens
leur qui cherchent un peu à exister
que ce soit à travers une célébrité ou à
travers d'autres
d'autres façons et ses impulsions qui
m'attriste énormément dans cette
nouvelle de cet homme qui était plein de
vie parce que moi c'est vraiment ce que
j'ai ressenti quand j'allais rencontrer
les prix finalement permis à lui dans la
tragique c'est vraiment je dise quelle
triste fin
déjà on voit les commentaires de gens
qui se désole des gens qui ne
connaissaient pas personnellement mais
qui s'était attaché à la masse qu'il
incarnait ce qu'il représentait l'image
aussi en date frondeurs d'être libre il
incarnait bonne chose ou bboy loric
jeunesse je vous rappelle mesdames et
messieurs qui décédé hier à montréal
pénélope merci beaucoup pour cette
entrevue
ben rien julie est vraiment une histoire
qui termine vraiment autrement qu'être
qu'on arrête plus
merci beaucoup peiné là